"Blue Ocean Strategy" is a business management book published in early 2005.
The book is based upon a "Harvard Business Review" article authored by W. Chan Kim and Renee Mauborgne.
According to the book's website,...
..."Blue Ocean Strategy" is a way to make the competition irrelevant...
...by creating a leap in value for both the company and its customers.
The authors divide the market universe into "Red Oceans" and "Blue Oceans".
Red oceans represent "The Known", the company's markets and industries that exist today.
Red oceans represent their defined and accepted limitations...
...and the competitive nature they foster as they battle for control of perceived limited resources.
This waging of corporate war turns the waters bloody, hence the term "Red Ocean".
Blue oceans represent "The Unknown", the company's markets and industries not in existence.
Within a blue ocean, unlimited opportunities to create markets and new demand await discovery.
Because of the vast potential within these blue oceans, competition is irrelevant...
...as the quote rules of the game have yet to be defined.
Blue Ocean Strategy contrasts starkly with Red Ocean Strategy...
...in that it seeks to escape from accepted market boundaries...
...and create new markets in order to leave the competition behind.
Value innovation is the core concept of the book's message.
By ignoring the competition and focusing strategic thinking on the buyer,...
...a leap in value results for both the company and its customers.
Adopting this approach increases a company's chance of survival and growth...
...in increasingly crowded and shrinking market spaces.
The book has been described by many as required reading for business executives...
...as it proposes six clearly defined principles they can use to create their own "Blue Ocean" strategies.